and how about our relationship to the
planet itself
you know climate change has become
humanity's problem
it wasn't caused by humanity it was
caused by a narrow
subset of humanity that for 300 years
has been consuming the ancient
sunlight of the world you know all
cultures
are myopic faithful to their own
interpretation of reality
and we too are products of our own
history
and culture when in the renaissance and
into the enlightenment
we tried desperately to liberate
ourselves from the tyranny of absolute
faith when descartes famously said that
all that existed
is mind and material with a single
gesture he deanimated the world and
flung out all notions of myth magic
mysticism and metaphor
to the extent that saul bella would
write science made a house cleaning
of belief and the earth began to be seen
as just a stage set upon which only the
human drama
unfolded we developed a kind of an
extractive model
whereby if the flight of a bird had no
meaning a mountain was mere material and
rock
ready to be mined most peoples around
the world
have established relationships with the
natural world based
not on extractive principles but on
reciprocity some kind of
iteration of the fundamental idea that
the earth owes its bounty to people
people in turn owe their fidelity to the
earth
and that simple equation elaborated
through ritual
and belief has a profound consequence in
terms of the ecological footprint of a
people
i like many of you was raised to believe
that a mountain
existed of rock ready to be mined that a
forest was cellulose
ready to be cut the point is it's not
whether a mountain is rock or as a
spirit it's how the metaphor plays out
in the relationship between human beings
and the natural world
most societies around the world see the
earth
as alive they see it as a force to be
engaged and and filtered through the
human imagination